إنها الرابعة صباحًا
، وطريق دبي الشهير 14 حارة يهز العيون
فارغة ، هذا ليس إغلاقًا مرغوبًا فيه
[موسيقى]
إنه احتفال بالرياضة
وحفلة لن تفوتها الشيخة التي
سافرت من البحرين للانضمام إلى أكثر من
20  000 من راكبي الدراجات في رحلة عبر
وسط مدينة دبي
مروراً بأشهر
معالم المدينة بالنسبة للشيخة ،
وهذا أكثر بكثير من مجرد نزهة ممتعة ، إنها فرصة
لإلهامني بتشخيص إصابتي بالسرطان عندما كان
عمري 18 شهرًا واضطروا لبتر ذراعي في
ذلك الوقت.
هكذا بدأت رحلتي
، جعلت مهمتها هي زيادة
الوعي وتشجيع
الآخرين على عدم السماح للإعاقة بإيقافهم
، لقد سافرت حول العالم لتتنافس في
سباقات الماراثون المتقشف والرجل الحديدي على
سبيل المثال
لا الحصر ، لم أقل أبدًا أنها كانت الخسارة  لقد فقدت
ذراعي مرة أخرى لأنني اكتسبت
كل شيء
عندما تم بتر ذراعي ،
هذه الرحلة جزء من تحدي اللياقة البدنية في دبي لمدة 30 يومًا
وهي مبادرة مدتها شهر تشجع
السكان على القيام بالنشاط لمدة 30 دقيقة
كل يوم شيخة هو تجسيد
لهذا التحدي الذي
يقود بالقدوة ويثبت للجميع
أن أي شخص
يمكنه التغلب على تحديات الحياة أنا فقط
أتنافس في داخلي
وأتحدى قدراتي فقط
وأريد أن أتحسن بداخلي
ولا أنظر إلى
أي شخص.  سأحاول التنافس مع أي
شخص بداخلي فقط
وهذا ما يجعلني أرغب في أن أصبح
أقوى في كل مرة
تنفّذ فيها [الموسيقى]